okay
all right here we are
welcome back a governor a study released
this week warns that the world has nine
years to avert catastrophic climate
warming oh when we were having such a
good time
what kind of climate policies are you
focusing on implementing in Colorado
first of all we're too late the
climate's already changing so I mean the
nine years was probably nine years ago
or 20 years ago well we can still avert
some of the worst out possible outcomes
um and we're going to be 100 renewable
energy by 2040 in Colorado 80 in just
seven and a half years and 23. renewable
meaning uh it's solar wind uh looking at
it uh at high a little bit of hydro and
uh geothermal I'm very excited about
especially geothermal where are you in
nuclear uh we're open to it if the
economics work I mean I think the big
question is how will the economics work
I mean right now it just hasn't proven
out yet so let's let's see where the
technology goes over the next five or
two the economics of nuclear hasn't
worked out no it hasn't I mean you know
I thought the big something block was I
mean obviously everyone is afraid of
another Chernobyl or another Fukushima
which is valid but you know you have to
you know make what did Obama used to say
don't make the perfect the enemy of the
good so were a lot of the technology is
driving is towards sort of smaller scale
modular nuclear it doesn't quite cost
out it's always seems like one of these
Technologies that's like 10 years away
you know but but there's a lot of
promising stuff on drawing boards
Engineers working on it it wouldn't be
these large plants that you you have in
the past the Terra nuclear is promising
I mean that Terra nuclear it's the
smaller smaller nuclear reactors that
make recycle the waste yeah otherwise
and and that's something we should be
okay and I would say geothermal is
really cool too the heat beneath our
feet right just tapping into this
existing power source of the Earth for
Passive Cooling and for electric so
that's also and fusion is that too pie
in this guy who knows I mean you know we
have Fusion it's called the sun let's
capture that right that's what Neil
deGrasse Tyson always says we have a
great nuclear reactor in this guy yeah
all right uh Ro this is for you do you
think the massive Tech layoffs announced
this week oh yeah bloodbath in Silicon
Valley or an economic Bellwether for
other Industries what's going on there I
fear that it is a concern I mean what
you have had is advertising slow down
because advertising isn't always the
first thing people need and so you've
had layoffs said Facebook you've had
layoffs at Twitter you've had hiring
freezes at some of the other companies
but consumer spending is still good and
since this is your area what do you make
of the musk takeover of Twitter is that
something that alarms you or do you
welcome it do you hate it you know what
I I said I said to him I said why in the
world would you want to be running the
day-to-day of Twitter like do you really
want to make a decision on whether Bill
Maher rocon has tweet should stay or not
I couldn't think of a worse possible job
just a point a points on board
independently to make that decision I
think he's gonna I think that's what
he's doing well look he I think he had a
terrible week and I'm a big fan of his
but retweeting the gay Pelosi story was
stupid and then advising people to vote
Republican because we need divided
government at a time when the
Republicans were standing for for ending
democracy was stupid but he's a genius
sometimes Geniuses are stupid I
uh
and I'm still on his team I think I
think it's great I think it'd be so good
for the Democrats to unshackle
themselves from woke Twitter this
election just proved they do best when
they have
you know the moderate guy who's not uh
beholden to woke Twitter Twitter does
not vote
George what it doesn't vote but I also
don't think we need to be afraid of
expressing her opinions
exactly that's what he's standing up for
we shouldn't be afraid I am afraid I got
off Twitter because everything I wanted
to say on Twitter I couldn't say on
Twitter why because it would just be a
it's such a Minefield to get canceled
you know that 99 99 I'm sure you know
this stuff 99 of the people who work to
Twitter half of them don't now
uh vote Democratic now even if you're a
Democrat you shouldn't like that that's
not healthy for any company or any
country
[Applause]
I'm not for censoring people on Twitter
I think that if you're gonna incite with
you I don't think ever did but if people
are inciting violence that's different
of course so clean that up yes but allow
a free exchange of ideas I have no
problem with it I have no problem
whoever Elon Musk wants to support
politically I mean it saddens me that is
not supporting reason in the Democrats
but that's that's his first amendment
right my problem is that you don't want
him making decisions over the Media
Forum he should have an independence I
just like to tweet pictures of my dog on
Twitter everything's like exactly yeah
well I wonder with all of this
especially in Silicon Valley when did
Democrats say that what happens at
Twitter what happens on Facebook is like
a utility it needs to be regulated like
utility is that going to be part of the
discussion in the coming years in any
wake because it is confusing even as a
reported track who's in control who
should be in control where does the
First Amendment end if it ever ends what
is the story because a lot of people are
arguing on Capitol Hill it should be
like a telephone company but it's it's
such a terrible analysis energy because
the telephone that's this is a free
speech issue not the the utility is this
like gas and power and stuff like that
but they're not televisions regulated in
a different way than social media is
that a utility television no we're
talking about FCC stuff the weird thing
about the Twitter thing is you know Elon
Musk has been a brilliant business
person right and I I just don't
understand paying 44 billion I think
that a lot of that value is just going
to evaporate I don't see how he turns
this into a you know a winner they said
that about the electric car and reusable
Rockets So I mean you know the guy is
not exactly he's not exactly without a
track record and he has plans to make
Twitter into something much bigger than
it is not just a place where you can say
whatever it's your picture your dog he
wants to have it like where you do your
Banking and I like some of these other
social Labs if he gets rid of the Bots
that'll help and he's doing that yes
okay uh Robert Democratic strategist
James Carville said Democrats would be
better off looking harder at Mississippi
than Florida following the overwhelming
GOP success in the state
I don't know whether that's sarcastic or
I don't know what well the question is
Florida now Out Of Reach for Democrats
in 2024 is he serious about Mississippi
that's it's more enriched it's a
challenge for the Democrats I think in
the coming years having spent a lot of
time in Georgia a lot of time in
Mississippi in Alabama how are they
going to win back the south in some
respects the Clyburn argument that
voting rights and redistricting needs to
be put front and center has helped the
Democrats make gains I mean to think
that there are two Democratic senators
from Georgia right now shows the
Democrats have made some inroads but
when you go to Mississippi when you go
to Alabama and you say I'm a reporter a
lot of people just turn away it's still
Trump country there and the Democrats
have struggled with the working class
and that's why the Bernie Sanders
campaign has often said you got to lead
with the economy in class to win back
working voters in places like
Mississippi yeah you're not going to get
Mississippi and Alabama I wonder what
are we why worry
wouldn't you want to play in 50 states
if you can no it's it's silly and that's
why they don't because some places are
just not in reach I mean you know either
is South Dakota
you know it just you can't win them all
there's all population wise exactly why
are there two Dakotas why is there one
we gotta go
last show of the season